[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
johnny depp's rebuttal case begins my
overall assessment of her opinions
is that they're not worth the paper
they're not written on how dep's experts
refute claims made by herds witnesses
and was amber heard's aquaman role in
jeopardy you know it when you see it and
the chemistry wasn't there here from
warner brothers executives plus none of
these tweets have anything to do with
the waldman statements they don't
include the waldman statements you know
these hashtags are only hashtags that
schnell
and in his opinion
felt that they were negative towards
miss harvey depp's experts say the
waldman statements didn't affect herd's
reputation and later perjury is
considered
an attack on the interest of justice
what it would take for amber her to face
perjury charges law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer amber
heard's team rests its case and johnny
depp's team calls a series of witnesses
during its rebuttal case law and crimes
anjanet levy is here with what one of
those witnesses said about amber heard
salary and whether statements made by
johnny depp's lawyer hurt her career
anjanet
well brian you may recall that richard
marks is an entertainment industry
expert he's a real mover and shaker in
hollywood and he knows how deals were
made he testified in johnny depp's case
in chief and now he was back in rebuttal
he is testifying about claims by amber
heard's expert that her career was hurt
significantly by statements made by adam
waldman on behalf of johnny depp now
heard's expert catherine arnold had
claimed her career was harmed by adam
waldman's statements to the daily mail
and his tweets claiming heard's
allegations of abuse were a hoax but
mark said that heard was a supporting
character in aquaman and her role in the
second film may have been scaled back
because she simply didn't have great
chemistry with the film's star jason
marx said heard's career was not harmed
in his opinion by either waldman or
johnny depp
do you have an understanding of whether
aquaman 2 was the last option in ms
herd's contract with warner brothers oh
no no aquaman 2 has not even been
released and warner brothers has
a fourth option for aquaman 3 or another
movies
where mira appears that character and
they've agreed to double the salary
again
so it's in success and that assumes that
they recast and that they make the movie
are you aware of ms arnold's testimony
that ms heard would have made several
million dollars on endorsement deals
such as the one she had with l'oreal do
you agree with that opinion after the
breakout moment that ms arnold talked
about christmas 2018
we didn't see
endorsement deals flocking to
miss heard
during that 16-month period before
adam waldman made a few statements mr
marks what's your overall assessment of
ms arnold's opinions in this case
my opinion as someone who's
made deals
as a deal maker for almost 50 years
is that
she calls herself an expert but she's
not
she doesn't have the background she
doesn't have the day-to-day
knowledge
and as richard mark said he's been in
hollywood for almost 50 years during the
his the case in chief for johnny depp he
had testified about how deals are made
in hollywood this is something he's been
doing for a long time he even referenced
swifty lazar's oscar party that was a
really famous event
years and years ago i remember hearing
about it as a kid on entertainment
tonight and stuff like that and that was
a party where people
wanted to be seen and wanted to make
deals so this guy's been around for a
really long time and obviously disagrees
wholeheartedly with catherine arnold on
the impact johnny depp or adam moldman
may have had on the bottom line for
amber heard
yeah and so richard marks in my opinion
was great on direct he seemed to not
just give conclusions but showed his
work so to speak were there any
calculations that really stuck out to
you
you know not particularly i mean that
this whole thing about the 50 million
dollars
i don't know how uh you know reaching
that number as catherine arnold did i'm
just not so sure about that
it just we didn't have an expert you
know she didn't really testify
and have charts and things like that as
to how that number you know she came up
with that so
nothing stuck out to me other than that
fact yeah now internet on cross heard's
team made a point uh that he had never
negotiated a superhero deal did that
lessen the strength of his testimony
that being marx
you know i i don't think it did you know
superhero he said you know she's not
jason momoa jason mamoa was the guy he
was the main character he is the person
who could walk in and get the big payday
somebody like amber heard couldn't walk
in and get that payday he also said
she's the type of actress who still has
to read and audition for a role this
isn't like somebody like jason mamoa who
they probably just call up his agent and
say we want him yeah and not like
zendaya either who she was trying to
compare uh the mj of spider-man but
anjanet where do you think this jury is
left after the rebuttal witnesses in
terms of amber heard's acting prospects
and damages
well i think that the the fact that
we've heard at least two witnesses now
say that there was just there were major
chemistry issues between jason mamoa and
amber heard it makes you wonder
maybe maybe there are issues with her
developing chemistry because chemistry
is something i think that people can
have we work in television we know about
chemistry right
it's something you guys can have
immediately or it's something that can
be developed so maybe there's just an
issue with development of chemistry with
her possibly and other actors now we'll
see how the chemistry works out in front
of the jerry internet hang out for a
minute we'll be back in a second still
ahead on law and crime daily attorneys
zero in on amber heard's role in aquaman
why a warner brothers executive says
there were discussions to replace heard
in the series
[Music]
welcome back as part of jeff's rebuttal
case jurors heard video testimony from
warner brothers executive walter hamada
president of dc films hamada says heard
had chemistry issues with aquaman
co-star jason momoa
was there any delay
in warner brothers exercising the option
to cast
misheard and aquaman few
yes it was
what was the cause of the delay
uh there were conversations about
potentially recasting they didn't really
have a lot of chemistry together um you
know the reality is
it's not uncommon on movies for for two
leads to not have chemistry and that
it's sort of movie magic and editorial
the ability to sort of put performances
together and with the magic of you know
a great score and and how you put the
pieces together you can you can
fabricate sort of that chemistry
um and so i think in at the end of the
day i think if you watch the movie they
look like they had great chemistry but i
just know that through the course of the
post-production that it took a lot of
effort to get there sometimes you don't
sometimes it's very easy you just put
the you know characters on screen
together and they work and sometimes
it's harder and so
can you give me anything more specific
about what it was with amber heard and
jason omoa that
was difficult for the chemistry now
because it's it's it's it's like what
makes a movie star movie star like you
you you know it when you see it and the
chemistry wasn't there
all right let's see how this chemistry
works in this q a joining us today is
entertainment lawyer dmitry hurian
co-host terry austin and long crime
correspondent anjanet levy mitra as an
entertainment lawyer listening to arnold
marx and now uh
um how does this work in this business
who is right
yeah so i think it's really important to
understand the way these deals work and
what an option is and the way options
work um options you're typically
negotiating the sequels or the second
movie or perhaps the prequel you
negotiate all of that in the primary
deal for the movie
and you might negotiate a bump in the
fee or a bump in the back end that
depends on how the movie before it did
the studio is under no obligation to
renew an option and they don't even have
to give you a reason why they didn't do
it
so it's complete discretion up to them
and the only way the movie moves forward
is if they give a written notice that
they've exercised the option and they're
moving forward with it which did not
happen here
that also plays a little bit into when
we talk about some of the numbers and
how speculative the proposed numbers
have been
um options again they're typically
pre-negotiated so we we should know what
those numbers are absolutely now terry
overall did you think that hamada was
credible as a witness
oh brian he was an excellent witness
first of all he was the president of dc
inc which is a subsidiary of warner
brothers and he's an unbiased witness
he's not for heard he's not for depth
and so he has no change in that quarter
and he not only
you know verified the fact that the
salary was not affected by waldman's
statements he confirmed there was no
chemistry between jason momoa and amber
heard he said she wasn't the co-star her
role was never reduced so he definitely
confirmed many aspects of this case for
the depth team and he was unbiased great
witness yeah great one is the only
critique i would have is i think i kind
of saw a lack of chemistry in the movie
myself but hey that's just my opinion
and jeanette as part of his deposition
hamada confirmed heard sally was not
affected by deb or waldman statements
how does herd's team come back from
something like that
i i don't think they can because her
salary was in the contract okay so it's
in there her salary was not impacted she
is not somebody richard marx said she's
not somebody who can go in and demand a
doubling or tripling of a salary based
on the success of a movie and that type
of role one thing i wanted to point out
too brian there are morality clauses and
a lot of contracts i don't know if they
exist in movie contracts but i do know
they do in television contracts and
that's another way where they can just
cut you out or or get rid of you
as if they deem that you've done
something to embarrass them so it'd be
interesting to know if that exists in
the contract as well absolutely and it's
going to be it's going to be crazy how
this plays out waiting for that
summation to come up thank you both and
janet great work as always coming up on
law and crime daily the analytics of the
johnny depp versus amber her definition
trial depp's internet analytics expert
takes the stand again but does his
findings match up with hers experts
that's ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back on tuesday depp's team
called a repeat witness as part of the
rebuttal case douglas bonya responded to
heard social media expert regarding the
correlation between statements made by
adam waldman that herd's allegations of
domestic abuse were made up and
subsequent negative social media
hashtags
so what i'm trying to do and what's that
issue of the case today today at this
point is
you know were these tweets did they
contain the waldman statements that's
what we're where we're at right now the
first thing that i noticed is 35
of the tweets were prior to the waldman
statements so again remember my
assignment is to determine if the
waldman statements are part of the the
tweets that mr schnell analyzed so
obviously if
these tweets were prior to the waldman
statements in no way could they have
anything to do with the waldman
statements you know these hashtags are
only hashtags that schnell and in his
opinion felt that they were negative
towards miss harvey mr schnell provided
no evidence that
any of the tweets
were related uh to the waldman
statements
um
mr schnell
there's no correlation there uh he also
provided no evidence that there's any
causation that you know
the waldman statements caused any
economic harm towards miss heard
all right terry maybe i'm too cautious
of a defense attorney but are we getting
close to the point where we're getting
lost in the weeds with this rebuttal
witnesses on the issue of social media
or is it still persuasive
well you know the jury might be a little
bit lost in the weeds but i think doug
banya is one of the most persuasive
witnesses that we've had certainly on ip
issues he basically was there to say
that ron schnell and catherine arnold
didn't know what they were talking about
they didn't make a correlation they
didn't make a causation connection
between the waldman statements and the
hashtags and i think it was effective it
was good for the jury to hear this at
least one more time there was no
connection to economic harm so i think
he was worthwhile even though it was a
little bit on the technical side yeah
major both sides seem to search based on
their own metrics to get the results
that they're looking for further aside
can a jury ignore either side and just
decide on their own and if they do what
do you think the verdict will be on this
issue
i mean i think that there's some
recognition that most scientific studies
and analytical studies have a premise
that they're basing off and in this case
he was basing it specifically off of the
waldman statements
but even at the end of the day i think a
jury will recognize that
this is correlation this is not
causation
and we need a causative link we need
x to be happening because of
y
um or why to be happening because of x
so
that's the biggest issue it's not the
information it's that that we don't have
the causation yeah correlation or
causation that's not going to be a
discussion in the jury deliberation room
and we'll see how that continues but to
keep up with the gavel together coverage
of the johnny depp versus amber heard
trial make sure to follow our newest
podcast lawn crime sidebar listen in as
some of lawn crime's top hosts recap the
highs and lows of the trial so far
straight from the fairfax county
courthouse in virginia subscribe on
apple podcast or online at lawncrime.com
when we come back could amber heard face
perjury charges still ahead what it
could take to convict the actress and
how likely it is she will be charged
[Music]
welcome back we're taking a closer look
now the testimony of amber heard could
the defendant in this case face perjury
charges while on crime network's sierra
gillespie explains what constitutes
perjury in virginia and what it would
take for her to be convicted
your signature appears right under the
statement quote i declare under penalty
of perjury under the laws of the state
of virginia that the foregoing is true
and correct
that is correct experts say some of
amber heard's recent testimony could
prove problematic i think there's a
level
of
falsity that is happening to the point
that
several witnesses might have also
committed perjury by going and going and
testifying on the stand
under oath under penalty of perjury and
providing a completely different fact
than another witness but the ongoing
defamation suit isn't herd's first bout
with perjury after illegally bringing
her and depp's dogs into australia in
2015 hurd was investigated for the crime
i am truly sorry that pistol and boo
were not declared
protecting australia is important
australian officials say that
investigation is still ongoing
closer to home depp's attorney adam
waldman says los angeles officials
opened an investigation into herd's
pergerous claims i filed a
claim with the lapd
regarding these perjurious statements
that ms heard and her best friend rocky
pennington had made simply put perjury
is lying under oath but trial attorney
catherine lazardo says it's a lot more
complicated perjury in virginia is a
class five felony what that means is
it's punishable by
one to ten years in prison but since
it's a class 5 it can also be downgraded
into a misdemeanor legal analyst dina
dahl says heard wouldn't be charged
right away let's say she loses and
basically the jury is deciding that she
is kind of lying about a lot of this
they're not deciding it beyond a
reasonable doubt it's only this
preponderance of evidence so she's not
kind of automatically
convicted of purging dahl explains it
would take a separate trial to convict
herd what would happen is a prosecutor
would have to bring a separate charge of
perjury against her and they would could
use this evidence of course at trial and
just how likely is it that hurd would
face perjury charges at the beginning of
this trial
when i was asked that i'd say i said you
know there's no way
anyone will be prosecuted for perjury
but as i listen to this more and more
and more
as a lawyer i am
ethically appalled
by any
perjury statements or even coercing a
witness to commit perjury on the stand
and to some extent i'm wondering if
there will be a message sent after this
trial that you cannot make these types
of statement
in court and not have ramification
reporting for law and crime network i'm
sierra gillespie
mitra in your mind what if any facts in
the case so far could lead to a perjury
conviction
well i think the fact of the donation is
a big one i think she was very much
caught in that lie
trying to differentiate between the word
pledge and donate saying that she uses
those words interchangeably
but the clear answer is she did not
donate that money that she promised to
donate to the aclu in the children's
hospital
um and
instead you know said that i got sued
for 50 million dollars in 2019 and
that's why i did not donate that money
um so there's a clear issue there the
other issue is the domestic abuse did
that happen did that not happen in a
case like this we are in a civil case
there's a he said she said a lot of
times it's going to be hard to show that
it was a flat out lie
as opposed to two parties having
different renditions of what what
exactly happened
in these situations you the reality is
we have two people who were drinking and
doing drugs and
in a toxic relationship you know and we
don't know exactly what happened
and does that amount to perjury
i don't know yeah now terry with that
the question then becomes on a scale of
1 to 10 10 being we're definitely going
to see this happen what's the likelihood
of seeing perjury charges here
you know i think the likelihood is very
slim i would say in most cases it would
be a 1 maybe here or two or three only
because like meter said we've seen so
many lies and those lies have been
really blatant but i think they'd have
to prove that it was false and we've
seen a lot of times the statements have
been i don't recall so we'll see what
happens yeah i would attempt to agree
with you as well at terry well thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
so
[Music]
you